zu unserer unvermeidlichen wöchentlichen
dosis putin kommen wir gleich jetzt
erstmal zum reinkommen was heiteres
deutsche innenpolitik an einem freitag
genau zwischen zwei landtagswahlen
übermorgen nordrhein-westfalen man hat
ist auch die kleine bundestagswahl
letzten sonntag schleswig holstein mit
einem ja wirklich unglaublichen
erdrutschsieg für daniel günther
wahnsinn oder war das der wahnsinn gut
wenn auch in einem bundesland mit circa
zwölf einwohnern davon drei schafe aber
trotzdem
43 das ist schon ein ausrufezeichen
überhaupt musste ich am wochenende alle
meine norddeutschland klischees
beerdigen sie abgeben da oben
ist aber sonst habe
[Applaus]
macht den helikopter 117 wie übrigens
auch der ideale song für den
zapfenstreich von verteidigungsminister
in lambrecht
in kiel gehen cdu grüne und fdp zusammen
ab auf der tanzfläche das ist genau der
stil für den daniel günther zu recht
gefeiert wird anderen parteien erfolge
gönnen und pragmatisch unideologisch
regieren da entsteht gerade echte
konkurrenz für friedrich merz ja
wirklich daniel günther jahre lang in
der cdu verspottet als genosse günther
gilt plötzlich als möglicher
kanzlerkandidat
ich behaupte dem märz geht die düse
freunde das merkt man schon daran wie
überschwänglich er den jungen
herausforderer lobt es ist eine
landtagswahl mit einem überragenden
ministerpräsidenten der in allen
politikfeldern überragende kompetenz und
zustimmungswerte als person hat ganz
ganz herzlichen glückwunsch zu diesem
über über überragenden erfolg ein tolles
wahlergebnis
überragend absolut bei so viel heuchelei
müsste ich die brille geschlagen ja die
beiden hier haben sich über jahre
geschätzt zur wahrheit gehört friedrich
merz versucht schon alte fehler zu
korrigieren neuerdings kann er sich
sogar eine frauenquote vorstellen wenn
der partei zitat nichts besseres
einfällt
ja daniel günthert gerade mit einer
paritätischen wahlliste triumphiert aber
klar am ende muss die union selber
entscheiden wen sie ins kanzlerin
schickt nun aber was würden sie zu hause
sagt nur aus dem bauch also ohne sie
beeinflussen zu wollen wer von den
beiden kommt ihnen spontan irgendwie
netter vor
ist geschmackssache würde ich sagen nett
ist natürlich keine kategorien politik
logisch aber es ist schon bezeichnend
dass der herr günther mit zwei
koalitionspartnern weitermachen will
obwohl ein erreichen würde weil die sich
mögen darum so und übermorgen sind dann
13 millionen wahlberechtigte in nrw
gefragt dem deutschen power bundesland
und wenn sie jetzt in sachsen-anhalt
sitzen und sagen was war nochmal nrw
hier unser service alles was man über
immer wie wissen muss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war alles was man über nrw wissen
muss
er verfügt also das war jetzt schon arg
verkürzt aber im prinzip völlig richtig
nordrhein westfalen oder wie wir es hier
vor der letzten wahl liebevoll getauft
hatten nordrhein katastrophen wie geht
es der liebenswerten industrie brache
zwischen rhein und ruhr nach fünf jahren
schwarz gelb sagen wir so auf der
plusseite haben sie ihre neuverschuldung
zumindest vor corona auf null gedrückt
es wurde mehr geld für verkehrsprojekte
rausgeholt und innenminister roll wird
zu recht gelobt für seinen kampf gegen
kriminalität auf der minusseite ist nrw
immer noch spitze bei staus und in armut
rankings im moment liegen union und spd
in umfragen sehr nah beieinander oder
analytischer formuliert das wird eine
spannende wahl denn es ist nicht ganz
klar wie sie ausgeht
hört doch auf
wahlen wo man nicht weiß wie die
ausgehen ich hoffe dass setzt sich nicht
durch meine damen und herren viel zu
aufregend eher unzufrieden sind die
bürger von nrw mit ihrer bildungspolitik
womit wir auch schon nahtlos bei der fdp
schulministerin yvonne bauer wäre ja die
es wegen ihres chaotischen corona
managements wirklich ein rotes tuch für
eltern und lehrer kein bundesland in
deutschland investiert weniger in seine
schüler cup hat die fdp 2017 noch
geworben mit welt beste bildung für
jeden bzw für jeden der nicht in nrw
wohnst
gerade mal 7500 euro gibt es da pro
schulkind und ja das sind für jeden
schultag popelige 39 eur 47 vorschlag
wenn man einem schüler die 39 euro
einfach morgens in bar gibt dann kann er
mit dem neuen euro ticket nach hessen
fahren da in die schule gehen in hessen
ist nämlich das kantinenessen inklusive
danach noch eine tages mitgliedschaft im
fitnessstudio beim sportunterricht fällt
ja sowieso immer aus anschließend wieder
nach hause und trotzdem hat er noch
genug geld übrig für den drogendealer
vor seinem nrw schulhof
winwin tja und die fdp wollte unbedingt
das schulministerium top idee im
nachhinein am sonntag heißt es also
hendrik wüst cdu gegen thomas kutschaty
oder wie viele bürger hier in nrw sagen
der eine mit der brille gegen den
kleinen von der spd
gut beide sind noch nicht so wahnsinnig
bekannt wüst zum beispiel hat sein amt
erst vor knapp 200 tagen und einer nicht
so richtig zu ende aufgeklärten mallorca
affäre von armin laschet geerbt gestern
abend war großes tv duell und da hatte
die redaktion echt mal ne hammer idee
man hat hendrik charlie und thomas wüst
oder umgekehrt zitate aus dem
parteiprogramm von spd und cdu
vorgelesen und die mussten anraten von
wem das jeweils ist
lief super wir werden uns beim bund
dafür einsetzen das bafög neu
aufzustellen und ein elternunabhängiges
bafög zu ermöglichen
das steht bei der cdu jedenfalls wir
brauchen mehr wohnraum der der
mietpreisbindung unterliegt
mietpreisbindung
es ist von der cdu tatsächlich es kann
nicht allein dem markt überlassen werden
wo welches krankenhaus mit welchem
medizinischen angebot steht
das ist von der cdu herrscht die
nächste frage wer hat sein eigenes
programm mich gelesen
und beide so
stößt hendrik wüst am sonntag vor in die
riege der möglichen cdu
kanzlerkandidaten oder holt thomas
kutschaty das land für die spd zurück
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller